good afternoon CS 109 how are you guys
doing
today oh my God it's so good to be back
as you guys know on Sunday night I got
very very sick and I continued to be
sick into Monday um it wasn't coid it
wasn't the flu uh it was something I
picked up for my daughter so it goes uh
but I feel so much better now and and
thank you to our wonderful ta teams I
you know on Monday morning I thought we
were going to councel class I was just
like I'm not feeling right let's see how
I feel and then by Monday midday I knew
there was no chance I could teach so
around that time I got in touch with the
TA teams and there's one ta I've got
some time Chris I think I can do this so
we were going to cancel class and we're
just going to not be able to see that
material uh and the whole class will be
pushed back and fantastic man we have
such a wonderful ta team I appreciate
all of them so quick Round of Applause
for our wonderful T someone looked at
our course they like I have never seen
so many office hours uh from a class and
that's because our Tas are doing like
the extra mile I've seen it in lots of
places where they're just staying late
to help students on the for the nice
messages they post we have a really
special team and you guys make my job so
wonderful good people to work
with um I have so many things to talk
about before we jump into material the
first one is I just want to make sure
we're grounded and where we are we
talked about counting Theory we talked
about core probability we talked about
random variables we put lots of Random
variabl together and now we're in a
section of cs19 where we talk about the
beautiful theories that everyone should
probably know we learned about beta
distributions and I hope you guys now
agree everyone really should know about
beta distributions um and then we talked
about adding random variables how that
led to Central limit theorem and how the
central limit theorem really inspired
really nice understanding of sampling
and today we're going to take that a
step further and we're going to be
learning about bootstrapping and on
Friday we'll talk about algorithmic
analysis I did also want to mention the
midterm because I was sick on Monday I
didn't get to talk that much about it
and there's not much more to add um one
small thing to add you guys have already
seen the distribution but have you
noticed how the distribution really
looks like it's baited distributed hm
peculiar that's not that important right
now there was this small misconception
of oh man if I got um you know 50 on the
midterm does that mean I basically
failed cs19 and the answer is no I asked
a pretty hard midterm with very real
world problems like all those problems
actually had correspondence to the real
world if you were in the real world
someone might give you that problem and
if you solved it it would be a big deal
so if you could solve all seven of those
problems that's amazing fantastic like
just keep doing your thing and if you
could solve all but one of those
problems man that's amazing too and if
you miss two problems that means that
you could do five out of seven or four
out of four out of six real world
problems that's really rocking you guys
are making good progress um and there's
a lot of different versions of you guys
have really impress me as a class to say
and I did want to drive home just well
okay I'll get to this in a second I did
want to drive home this point and you
guys uh know probability well enough to
understand what I'm trying to say here
three random variables G is your grade
in the class s is the score you got in
the midterm why did I keep hitting the
wrong button and D is the difficulty of
the midterm and what am I trying to say
with this equation probability of your
grade taking on the value L little G is
equal to the probability of grade taking
on the value l g given D equals D what
am I trying to say
here yes dependent of how difficult yeah
exactly all I care about is what you
guys know I I ask real world problems
that are complicated you know to give
you the scenario um but uh asking a
harder exam doesn't should not change
your belief in the difficulty and that
was a hard exam um and then there's one
other policy that I need you guys to
know about which is that I really
appreciate that exams are a bit
stochastic and sometimes people walk
into the midterm and maybe they weren't
as
prepared did you have a bad midterm it's
fine great still in your control for
lots of of reasons one is that problem
says count for a lot one is that there's
this optional contest which we'll talk
about in a second but also I have a
policy of always looking at people's
final exam scores and if I look at your
final exam score I look at your midterm
score I was like that's pretty
substantial Improvement between the two
I'll recognize that the final exam score
is cumulative so you've showed me that
you learned I don't necessarily care
what you knew at the mid quarter I know
care about what you know at the end so
if you use this midterm as a diagnostic
and you can improve and you can show
that Improvement in the final you don't
have to get an A+ the final for this to
kick in um but if you can show
Improvement then I always recognize that
cuz I appreciate people working hard and
people trying to improve themselves what
a beautiful
thing okay another quick announcement if
you want to improve yourself one of the
cool things you could do is go check out
the cs19 problem set party you go to the
pet app uh and at 7:15 there'll be a
little notification that goes out if you
click on it we'll try and put you with
like a group of people or another person
in class and you guys can just like
either have a social moment or you can
teach each other something or you can
just like commiserate about something
All is fair uh and this is not that
important but I asked our AI overlords
what do students at Stanford learn
together at a pet party look like and
this is what they gave me back I'm not
going to interpret it but I just thought
that was
interesting okay and then finally as you
guys know one of the reasons that CS 109
great still under your control is
because there's lots of ways of showing
us that you know probability one of the
ways is to express what you've learned
in probability about something you care
about in your own life and that's one of
my favorite ways that you could express
it totally op and optional in the sense
of the word that if you don't do it
you'll get the same grade as if it
didn't exist but if you do do it this
contest what a cool thing all the
details on the
website okay we're going to learn
something really really really cool but
I need to motivate it I need to give you
could you grab me a glass of water okay
thanks I guess I haven't been talking
for a couple
days I want to motivate
it by the end of today's class you
should be able to answer problem that
that looks like this and at first it
doesn't seem that important but let me
tell you this is one of the more
profound questions you can ask in
science okay imagine you have two
different learning context and you want
to figure out is one better than the
other so you have a certain number of
people do learning context a and you
have a certain number of people do
learning context B one of the first
things you do is for each person you
measure their outcomes and then you take
the mean and you say in learning context
one the mean was 3.1 and learning
context 2 the mean was
2.4 and then I asked you this question
question it says is this difference in
means of 7 meaningful and how confident
are you in the claim that are you in the
claim that they're how confident are you
in the claim that group a is in fact s
points better than Group B it doesn't
seem that meaningful it seems nice to
know right like you should be able to do
that but it doesn't seem so critical but
the reason it's so critical is this is
the classic SCI test if you ever want to
write a science paper in almost any
discipline whenever you make a claim
you have to talk about the probability
of your confidence in your claim a thing
called A P value so if you want to do
biology or chemistry or physics or
computer science and you want to do
maybe uh uh computational education
anything in that space if you did an
experiment and you came up with a result
and that result has a claim you have to
associate a probability with it and
today not only will you be able to
associate a probability with this most
classic sort of result of differences
and means you should be able to talk
about a probability of any claim that
you could make in a scientific paper how
cool does that sound who wants to know
how to do a P
value yeah okay bear with me because
we're going to get there by the end of
today's class and actually we'll get
there by you know the middle of today's
class but first a little bit of a review
this whole story starts with the central
limit theorem the central limit theorem
what a beautiful thing if you take
different and un IID random variables
and you sum them up no matter what IID
random variables they are uh and um as
long as n is large enough it will always
converge to a normal the sum will always
converge to a normal and there's another
version of this which means if you take
that sum and multiply by 1/ m AKA you
take the average the average of IID
random variables is always normally
distributed and that is a powerful thing
that showed up in the world of sampling
remember sampling you have a population
but you can't get numbers from every
single person in your population so you
talk to a subsample of them and you know
new numerically
and in notation we'll represent our
sample as a list of random variables
we'll think of them all as IID they're
independent but they're pulled from the
distribution of the population so if
this green is the population
distribution we're imagine we're get 200
samples from this population
distribution because of the central
limit theorem some beautiful things come
out first of all if you have a sample
the mean of your sample is
unsurprisingly take all of them add them
up divide by n we learned that a long
time ago in like sixth grade what you
might not have learned about in sixth
grade though is if you want to know the
variance of your sample you can estimate
that and it looks so much like the
equation for variance except for this
cheeky n minus one it's so cheeky go
check out lecture to learn why there is
that n minus one but basically if you
don't have that n minus one because
you're estimating uh expectation or
because you're estimating the sample
mean you'll get this wrong uh you will
have a biased estimate
and then finally this very CS 109 in
sight sample mean is a random variable
and that makes sense every time you take
a sample and get a number it's going to
be different so even though you get a
value it'll take on different numbers
probabilistically it's a random variable
and because of that you can ask
questions like what's the standard
deviation and I've told you nothing
about the underlying distribution and
even though I've told you nothing about
the underlying distribution I can tell
you how you could calculate the standard
deviation of its mean that's insane and
it all comes from the central limit
theorem because the central limit
theorem tells us that the variance of
the average of I ID random variables is
a particular square root of the true
variance divided by how many things
you've added up um then we can know what
is the variance of the standard
deviation of the sample mean if any of
this is new certainly review Monday's
lecture
oh there is this really cool example
that did where he actually took all the
times it took people to complete the
problem Set uh problems and then for
each one we calculated the standard mean
and also the standard deviation of the
standard or standard deviation of the
sample
mean I want to just point out one more
thing we're talking about statistics
here right like you had a sample and the
two statistics that we could talk about
particularly for this sample is what's
the mean of the sample we could talk
about the variance but often we write
error bars which is the standard error
and standard error is just that um
standard deviation of the sample mean
and so the standard deviation sample
mean that's what error bars are those
are just statistics so if you took any
one number if you expand it out there's
a whole distribution underlying um and
uh I did want to just highlight that
we're talking about statistics not about
the underlying distribution am I making
sense okay anyone curious about what
that distribution is this is how long it
took people to do the a medical
diagnostic problem on the problem set
and you're like we all feel for these
people respect uh and but what
distribution do you guys think this is
you guys curious I'm curious too I don't
think anyone knows I think it might be
Airline which is the sum of exponentials
so it's like there's five Concepts you
need and it's amount of time to get
concept one plus amount of time to get
who knows could be Airline could be
Gumble which is a Max of exp or or Max
of different random variables we could
talk about this offline it's really not
important right now but the important
part is to keep reinforcing in your
minds the difference between a statistic
about a random variable and the
underlying
distribution lots of people care about
statistics but if you could walk out of
cs19 caring a little bit more about the
underline distribution my heart would be
so filled oh yeah okay Airline versus
Gumble not that important right
now but what about Bhutan on Monday we
left with this deep mystery we were
making a report for the government of
Bhutan and the government of Bhutan had
asked us can you report on the happiness
of our people so we took a sample of 200
people we reported the average happiness
and then we reported the sample uh the
variance of the sample that we got of
the 200 people and we used this equation
where you use n minus one to make sure
there's an unbiased estimate fantastic
and then we showed it back to the king
of Bhutan and King Ban's like what are
you doing there's no air bars there
we're like oh oh yeah of course so
Monday's class we're like we're going to
add some error bars and first of all
adding error bars to this estimate of
the mean was really straightforward we
would just use the fact that this a mean
comes from the central limit theorem we
know it's going to be Gan we know that
its particular variance is going to be S
Sid by n and the standard deviation of
our estimate should be this value we've
got error
bars and we go to the king of Bon we
like we got air bars the king of Bon's
like no you don't you have error bars on
one of your statistics what about your
error bars
here
uhoh and you're like huh well we got
these error bars
because xar was the sum or is a the
average of ID random variables Central
limit kicked in we could know its
variance and you're like is this the sum
of IID random variables and you're like
ooh I don't know you're like squaring
things and then I'm not sure this is
actually going to turn out to be gy and
it turns out if you went down this path
and tried to figure out eventually
Central limit theor applies here it
turns out it
doesn't you can't just use our old trick
so what I'm going to teach you is a
general trick anytime somebody wants you
to know about a distribution of
statistic anytime somebody wants you to
know P value for science hypothesis
we're going to use this one most
beautiful randomized algorithm
which is called bootstrapping and it's
one of my favorite randomized algorithms
I think it it would show up in every
probability class if people knew how to
program because it is such a powerful
tool for understanding the underlying
probabilities particularly from data I
think every data science class would
teach it every probability class would
teach it but not everybody knows python
the way that you guys do bootstrapping
is going to be an algorithm and it's
going to solve two separate problems if
you want to know about a distribution of
Statistics like you want to know what's
the variance of my standard uh de or of
my estimate standard deviation you could
know that for any
statistic and the generalization of that
is you can calculate these most
important things for science called P
values and it's going to take advantage
of the fact that you have computers and
if you ask your computers to work hard
they can figure out these P values for
you and it's just going to take a little
bit of probably Theory to get there
so let's go back to that ch we had with
the king of Bhutan the king of Bhutan
said estimate the variance of happiness
in my country and we gave the king of
Bhutan a number we said the variance of
Happiness was I'm going to make this up
because I can't remember but 420 or
something like that standard deviation
would be square root and the king of
Bhutan is what is the variance of your
estimate what are those error bars or
the standard deviation of your
estimate so you want to know standard
deviation so you could give
these error
bars but that was hard to do and we
don't have a solution I'm going to give
you a simpler way to come up with the
solution I'm going to tell you the
happiness of every person in Bhutan
that's right I'm going to let just cheat
a little bit and you're like once I know
that do I even need to know the standard
deviation of my estimate and like no you
wouldn't need it we're cheating because
obviously we're not going to talk to
every person in Bhutan but imagine we
had we've talked to every single person
in Bhutan and after we talk to every
single person in bhon what do we
have you could say we have a
histogram and on the x axis is people's
happiness
values which are obviously numbers
between like one and 10 uh and on the Y
AIS you could think of this as a
histogram but better yet if you
normalized it
this should be the probability Mass
function so you should say the
probability that the happiness of some
person equals little H where this x-axis
is little H so my question for you is I
give you the full probability Mass
function of happiness in
Bhutan and now I ask you this question
can you tell me how bad was my estimate
420 for
variance and particularly I got this
estimate after talking to 200 people
that 200's important you know if I got
my estimate after talking to 10,000
people maybe I should be pretty
confident but after talking to 200
people I should have some room for doubt
in my
number this is a hard question to think
about but I want you to figure it out
because if you could figure it out then
the whole rest of this lecture is going
to flow like water in a beautiful Canyon
so let's see if we can figure it out how
could you estimate how bad your measure
of sample variance was if I gave you
access to everybody in bhuton
yes question expect value of sare
difference uh I'm going to let you guys
I don't have the answer yeah you guys
are going to think about it that was a
good proposal answer but think think
about it what would you do there's other
ideas and think about you can use
computers as much as you want imagine
you have a laptop which is as powerful
as your I don't know
Smartwatch okay good fantastic think
about it let's see if we can figure this
out let's vent some cool stuff so how
are we going to get this estimate if
people have questions if there's
something unclear just raise your hand
one of the T will come and answer your
question okay yeah go talk about with
the person
next okay thank you it
pass
is
thanks man
app if you have any questions raise your
hand we'll come
answer
okay let's do this and if I could focus
everybody on one part of today's lecture
it would be this one because if we can
really crack this and understand what
we're doing here I appreciate the why is
not as deeply motivated but if you can
understand the mechanism then we'll be
able to follow the rest of the lecture
so let's make sure we take the time to
get this
right just to make sure we're all on the
same page variance is the measure of
spread so the king of Bhutan doesn't
just want to know average happiness they
want a statistic of how much happiness
spreads because if that's low then
everyone has close to the average but if
it's high then you'll have some really
happy people and some really unhappy
people so that measure of spread is
something the king of Bhutan wanted but
because we only talked to 200 people we
don't have the variance we have a thing
called the sample variance which is our
estimate of spread based off of just
talking to 200 people it's not going to
be the right number we only tou to 200
people and as such we want to know how
much this number would have changed if
we talked to a different 200 people we
want some measure of how much this
number is changing and we're getting
meta I appreciate how meta we've gotten
you variance and now we asking for
variance of the
like or if you're into square roots
standard deviation the standard
deviation standard
incredible questions clarifications
let's talk about things before we talk
about ideas yes yeah so this is the meta
part that I don't fully get I think the
So when you say the standard deviation
of the sample variance what are we
measuring the spread around are we
measuring the spread around a mean yes
this should be around the mean oh the
sample
variance sample variance is an unbiased
es because we got that n minus one in
there it turns out whatever you get for
sample variance is what we call the mean
of the sample variance so it's it's
around the number you got so if the
number you got when calculating sample
variance was 420 this will be the
standard deviation around that
420 long story short does that answer
the question
awesome other
questions yes is our sample is our
sample variance is that considered a
random variable yeah it is that's a
really good point so it's a random
variable so underneath the hood it's
going to have a distribution what does
that distribution look
like have you guys ever seen a
distribution of
variances oh my God today is a first in
your lives can I tell you what it looks
like I didn't plan to do this but I want
to I'd like to tell you what you've
never seen a distribution of variances
oh man okay well first of all what's the
distribution of means look like it's
gaussian because of central limit
theorem distribution of variances it
depends what the variance
is sometimes it looks like
this sometimes it looks like this it can
depend but notice a big difference
between means and variances means can be
negative variances can never be negative
this is not gaussian but anyways you
asked a good question and then I went on
a total
trade is variance is sample variance
this thing a random variable you bet it
is and it's got a distribution we just
never saw it before
today yeah at the beginning of class you
said that the way that we worked out the
mean variance doesn't work for the way
that we work out the variances variance
can you clarify that yeah this is your
sample mean and this is its distribution
if you took 200 different people you
would get a different sample mean it
will vary around what number you
calculated and it's going to be a gaan
like if you played 10,000 times the game
of getting 200 people getting their
sample means and plotted it you would
get a gaussian because cenal limit
theorem because cenal limit theorem we
know exactly what's the variance of this
Gan that's not a gan Central Li theorem
is not our friend today well it's always
our friend it's just not the friend that
can solve our problem okay one more
question I do need to jump into things
use like like some sort of involving be
able to avoid using strap to answer this
question I want to avoid that because
there are shortcuts that people have so
okay let me just generalize this
question there are shortcuts to several
of the questions I'm going to ask you
today where somebody might have done
some math to propose an answer to just
that question what I'd like to teach you
today is a way to answer all of the
questions so a much more General method
so yes there are ways you can circumvent
bootstrap basically for any problem but
bootstrap is like your Swiss army knife
tool and if you can Master this tool
then all these problems you don't have
to learn a Kai Square test or a t test
or all these different mini tests you
can just use the power of python and
your understanding of probability it's a
beautiful thing it's like the most ts19
thing in the world I'm so
excited okay so now we know what we're
doing how could we do it and I am
looking for pretty simple ideas so if
you had access to all of bhutan's
Happiness
values my idea is is there some way you
could possibly see the distribution of
your sample
variance
whoa Insanity not
possible maybe it is
possible
yeah you could repeat 10,000 times let's
start with that okay so yes we're going
to repeat 10,000
times what are we going to do 10,000
times
though okay an idea
[Music]
um and then because we have the whole
distribution we could just recreate
talking to 200 people I mean we're
trying to understand how wrong we worth
200 people so we should take 200 when
we're trying to understand this so we're
going to pull 200 random
people okay and then we calculate sample
we using that very nice formula we had
for Monday's
class and we've done this 10,000 times
that's going to give us 10,000 different
estimates for sample
variance guess what happens if you took
all those 10,000 things and made them
into a
histogram you get to see your own
standard the
distribution of variant that would come
from talking to 200
people fantastic that's on fire that's
that's
awesome
so does everyone I want to pause here
this would work but we're missing one
step how do we then get the standard
deviation of sample
variance at this point we've got our
whole
distribution from 10,000 times of
repeating my experiment after repeating
my experiment 10,000 times every single
time I got a value and if you
histogrammed it you would get the whole
distribution of sample variance maybe
when you talk to 200 people you got this
number maybe when you talk to 200 people
you got this number if you got crazy
unlucky you might get this number but
the probability will be governed by the
distribution once I have the whole
distribution it should be easy to get a
statistic like standard
deviation once you do this you have the
whole distribution and once you have the
whole distribution you can just
calculate standard
deviation man that's crazy like I really
appreciate that I have pushed us all I
may just think about standard deviation
of variant this is insane but I want to
pause and see if there's any what's
confusing about this here because if
it's confusing to you it's confusing to
somebody else yes I'm confusing about
the value of when you do one of those
Loops what you take example is the value
of the random VAR a random variable a
value in itself or distribution in
itself I know the old ad was it's a
sample and a sample is interesting we
often write it as a random variable but
it will be a number when you calculate
it like when you run this Loop in your
computer you'll get a
number but if I were to write this in an
equation I'd probably say Like You Know
sample one then you can say sample two
but this time it's a sample of your
sample
variance but does that make sense so
they will be numbers like when you run
this in your computer you're going to
get 10,000 numbers it's 10,000 different
like values and they're going to be IID
pulls from your sample variant you get
10,000 IID pulls from your sample
variants
so you have you're basically estimating
the pmf of the of
squ by yeah that that's exactly we
estimating the probability Mass function
of s s and that is giving us all the
information we want to know about s
s yes an idea um why would it not be a
normal distribution then if it's I good
question not everything that's IID is
normal are things that are added
together U like if you add up IID random
variables that's normal if you average
IID random variables that's normal but
the equation for standard variance
doesn't lead to something that's normal
and one thing I could also point out too
is that variances can't be
negative and you know normal
distributions have no limits on what
values they can take
on yes from these 10,000 variances how
do you calate the same deviation ah so
once you have 10,000 Things you've got
this histogram and then you can use your
classic variance from the midterm
equation where you just take you know
expectation of X squ div expectation of
x^ squ being a square rooted or you can
use your friend Python and say like np.
variance and then you just put in your
samples and it'll give you the
variance why does it matter that we know
the true distribution if we're just
pulling samples
anyway to my next Insight okay but let
me be clear about what we've done so far
if I gave you access to every person in
Bhutan we can now talk about how wrong
we were when canceled the full variance
and we could talk about that by
expressing the full distribution of
sample variance but your question is why
do we need access to everybody in Bhutan
and it's important because we don't have
access to everybody Mutan that kind of
breaks the whole scenario we'd like to
be able to do this with only access to
our 200 people I'll take one more
question before I jump into the next
part uh is is there maybe like just an
established like how much you have to
we can talk about the S line but that's
it depends a little bit okay so where we
are
is 10,000
times take a mock sample talk to a mock
200 people calculate the sample variance
now you've repeated your experiment
10,000 times and because you've repeated
10,000 times you can think about how
wrong any one experiment is because you
can think about you know how different
it could be from the true
variance
so here's my crazy crazy claim so you
guys are halfway through this
wonderfully complicated and beautiful
idea called the bootstrap so what we've
talked about is the first idea that if
you want to know about some statistics
just repeat many times and recreate the
experiment as good as you can calculate
your statistic then you'll have 10,000
versions of it and that's the full
distribution that's the first
half the second half is a bit of a leap
of faith we don't have access to
everybody in Bhutan what we have access
to is fewer people imagine say we had
access to 1 2 3 4 five six seven eight
people if I histogrammed this and then
normalized it we can think of this as
you know a probably an estimate of
probably Mass function you know what's
my estimate at this point that
somebody's happiness is 90 well I saw
one out of eight people with 990 so you
know maybe we'll or maybe there's 10
here H anyways I saw close to one out of
you know 10% of people with 90 happiness
so I could estimate that's probably
somebody has happiness 90 never saw
somebody with happiness 91 so that's not
possible I saw two people with happiness
92 uh just one person with 93 and I saw
a whole bunch of three people with
happiness
94 so this sample we can represent it as
a histogram and that histogram has a
nice analogy with a probability Mass
function because a normalized histogram
is a pretty nice approximation of the
probability Mass function from your
data somebody at Stanford not too long
ago I don't know what they were doing
but they had this wacky
idea they said if I don't know all the
people's happiness in Bhutan and all
I've got are these
samples then this probably Mass fun
function is a pretty good
approximation of the true probability
Mass function of all the happiness of
people in
Bon and people are like what that's
crazy yeah he's like the distribution
you get from the histogram of your
sample is a pretty good estimate for the
true underlying
distribution crazy the first time I saw
that I was like I like nope that's not
right turns out it was right and this
guy got like all these wordss for
figuring this out but you know if you go
back to our true distribution of
Happiness if we see in 100
samples you know six people with
happiness
two what's our best estimate for the
probability that happiness equals 2 well
according to the very first definition
we had of probability we had 100
samples and let's say we got seven
people with happiness equal to two
therefore our best estimate for the
probity that happiness equals 2 is about
7 over
100 as 100 increases this will be a
better estimate but you know based on
this underlying assumption it's not that
crazy extension to say well if you
extend this to happiness equals 1
happiness equals 2 Happ equals 3 you get
to the conclusion that your samples
pretty good estimate of the true
underlying probabilities
and then he put those two things
together because now we've got some
peanut butter and we got some jelly and
we're going to make a delicious sandwich
so what's the peanut butter is that we
could estimate our distribution of
something like sample variant by
repeating a whole bunch of experiments
and now that jelly is if you only have
200 people pretend that's all of
Bhutan consider that the probably Mass
function and when you get 200 more
people you're going to pull from that
probably Mass
function from the original 200 people
insane let's make that a little bit more
graphic this leads to the bootstrap this
is our beautiful peanut butter and jelly
sandwich bootstrap goes like
this you are going to estimate the
probability Mass function using the
sample so you start with your 200 people
from Bhutan Step One is take those 200
people and make your histogram and then
estimate your probably Mass function
from the
histogram then 10 10,000 times we're
going to do this pull 200 people and
calculate the statistics we cared about
and then we have 10,000 draws from Arch
statistic okay now how do you pull 200
people from the probity Mass function I
think that's the interesting thing by
the way for now let's start thinking
about estimating the mean we know the
central limit theorem will tell us the
right answer but this will be a nice
warmup to the bootstrap we'll then do
something more interesting
here's how you could get the bootstrap
to estimate how wrong your mean was so
you estimated mean you're probably a
little wrong how wrong were you here's
what the bootstrap says first of all you
gave me 200 people the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to take those
200 people and I'm going to build a
probability Mass function it's going to
look like this here my happiness scores
go from zero to like I don't know 120
but anyways you take all your happiness
scores you histogram them and then you
say that you know the probability
somebody gets 61 it's the number of
times I saw 61 divided by the number of
samples I had in my data set insane
according to this guy at Stanford not
insane so now we've got a madeup
probably Mass function an estimated
probably Mass function if you will and
the next thing we're going to do is say
that's Bhutan that's all the happiness
of all the people and once we've assumed
that and that is an assumption then
10,000 times we're going to do
this draw 200 samples from this probably
Mass function then we're going to
recalculate the mean and then we're
going to save it so let's draw our 200
samples recalculate the mean from these
200 samples so sorry I squiggled drawing
200 samples but you get the point right
you draw 200 samples they're not exactly
the same blue
distribution and you take the mean of
those 200 samples and I'm going to add
it to a list of means I've done my Loop
once you guys ready for me to do it
again next time through the loop I pull
another 200 people from bhuton but of
course I don't have all of Bhutan
instead I'm going to use my estimated
probability Mass function insane but
beautiful at the same time and once I do
this then that red is going to be my 200
pulled people I recalculate a new mean
from my 200 pulled people and I add this
to my list I now have two estimated
means were the same no
you know when I pulled each time when I
pulled 200 people I got a different 200
people so when I took their means I got
different numbers they were pretty
similar which is a good sign if they
were really different that's a bad sign
for how well we're estimating the
mean if we do this 10,000 times I'll end
up with a list of size
10,000 and the crazy thing about
bootstrapping is that it says this is
the distribution of means cool or what
okay of course it's not that cool who
cares about distribution means it's cool
when it gets to science so if your
original sample is like only 200 for
example then if you're redrawing a
length 200 sample from that sample is
everybody in that SLE think about it as
every time you withdraw it's with
replacement so it's not just every time
I draw a person from this probably Mass
function the probably Mass function
doesn't change okay it's not like one
person gets removed so every time I draw
it's from the same proba mass function
so for example I could possibly draw 200
people with that happiness it's unlikely
but possible good question yes how
confident can we be that this is because
like what if my 200 sample let's say
this is to just like really unusually
happy people that just mess up our whole
process yeah it turns out that there's a
lot of proofs that show that this
converges very quickly to the right
answer so at the point where you're at
200 it's possible that something out of
you know distribution would happen but
very very very very unlikely and people
trust this immensely because there's a
lot of evidence behind it yes is there a
minimum amount of people we need to
sample I'm like what if you sampled only
like 10 people I've never seen somebody
attempt this when you had fewer than 200
samples to start with so that's a good
question but you probably probably
people have done it with like a 100 but
I've never needed to yes just clarify
work out a new need from sampling this
original sample and you distribute that
new be that you yeah every time loop I
get brand new people and a brand new
mean so I'll end up with 10,000 brand
new
means
yes on like if you had say only 200 200
people do SLE 200 it's a survey dat set
so I'm really struggling to understand
how it replaces itself yes so um let's
say there's five samples and I'm going
to resample five from that how's that
sound can we start with that and then
we'll extend to
200 so in my original sample let's say
it's binary it's zeros and ones
few and in my original sample I only had
five people what am I doing
bootstrapping for well anyways there was
two people in my original sample who had
a zero and three people who had a one so
I'm going to say two out of five people
had a zero uh and three out of five had
a one those are probabilities now when I
pull five new people it's possible that
my five every time I pull a person it
doesn't change this distribu
so now I'm going to draw people first
person I pull is a zero that could
happen right I'm going to draw four more
people next person is a zero that can
happen next person I draw is a
zero that can happen every time I'm
drawing with this constant probability
so there's always a two fths chance of a
zero and I could go and I could pull
five
zeros so even though the original
distribution did not have five zeros
when I pull five times from the uh
imagine proba Mass function I could get
zeros so you could see something that
was not in the original
distribution yes if like of the original
pmf one of these happened to be zero so
like wouldn't that zero carry on to the
all the rest people you pick like You'
never have another 61 for example if
that was zero and the original came
sorry oh yes so if there is some value
and you never see a person for that
value what do you do school two schools
of thoughts one school of thought says
that's a zero it's not possible didn't
see it in 200 not possible and there's a
bean school of thought which is like
maybe we can do some little pla
smoothing here and we can like add in
some uh observations about thing so
there's people who get really fancy
about it but um for now we're just going
to say yeah you didn't see in your
sample not possible after the in the
list you said it was like it's a good
thing that they were similar to each
other isn't it doesn't it like make
sense that they would be each other
because we're pulling from the same
thing yeah and in fact because these are
me means not only does it make sense but
we can know everything without even
having done the
bootstrap because the central limit
theorem tells us that the distribution
means will be gaussian and we know that
its mean will be expectation of X and we
know that the variance will be equal to
um the square root of the distribution
of the average of IID random
variables so that's going to be the
square root of n * Sigma did I get that
right n time
uh okay
51 Central limit theorem says if you
average n random variables it will be
gaussian and its variance will be Sigma
squide n and so the average will be
gaussian and it will follow that
distribution and if you looked over
here at slide
51 you if you looked at this
distribution it would be gaussian and
its variance would be the true variance
of the random variable Sigma squ / n and
then you can ask questions like what's
the probability that your true mean is
in the range 81 to
85 but to be clear after we've done our
10,000 samples experiment if I want to
answer the question what's the
probability that the true mean is in the
range 81 to 85 how could I do this using
my 10,000 means so to be clear after
bootstrapping I've got 10,000 versions
of the sample mean how can I answer the
question what is the probability that
the actual mean is in the range 81 to 85
I want you to talk about with the person
next to you but before you do that as
the person next to you is there anything
confusing about this if you guys got a
good question keep this wonderful
wonderful conversation going because
I've really appreciate all the questions
so far so what's confusing and then how
could you answer this question using
your 10,000
samples
e
I
take 40 more
seconds
okay so as we mentioned
one answer to this is that you could
take your underlying Knowledge from the
beautiful expression of nature that is a
central limit theorem that says if you
ever average random variables it will
always be distributed as a gan amazing
and not just any gan gan whose mean is
equal to the true mean of the things
that you averaging together and whose
variance is equal to the true variance
of the underlying random variable
divided by n because of that you can
know this
distribution just by first estimating
the sample variance dividing by n and
then you could know how much that this
thing has a spread you could estimate
the the expectation of this by just
calculating xar it's a beautiful thing
and then you can calculate this but
there's an easier way if we've just
bootstrapped and we have
10,000
samples from this distribution of the
sample mean there's an easier way to
answer the question what's the probity
that the mean is range 81 to 85 did
anyone come up with that easier way yeah
by counting just by counting but tell me
more um just count the
ones
yeah I want you to guys start seeing
lists and imagining probably
distributions can we start doing that
you see a list anytime in life you're
like going to be in cs1 XB and they're
like here's a list and you start seeing
probably distrib is like what did Chris
do to me anywayss if you see a list
especially if there's samples I want to
see a probably distribution and then
your claim of counting is very good you
said take this list and say what
percentage of things in this list are in
the range that we cared about and that's
a good estimate for the probability that
something drawn from this random
variable would be in that
range I have so much appreciation for
how deep this lecture is going and I
really appreciate how hard you guys are
working to follow this not easy stuff
but powerful important stuff that leads
to a tool that you'll use for hopefully
the rest of your scientific
lives Okay so we've answer this
question I've set the stage we should be
able to do this I now want to add error
bars to this report to Bhutan before we
take this and start to do p values for
science so how do we take this and get
standard deviation of this estimate so
we got 400 something close to 450 was
our estimate for the variance of
happiness in Bhutan but that estimate
was wrong bootstrapping tells us how
wrong it might have
been yes why should we trust bootstrap
just as much as the central limit
theorem do you have like uh like
controls to like test how fast the
approximation is working and yeah just
in like the central limit theorem how
there's both um mathematical evidence
people have actually done proofs to show
that this converges to the right thing
as there is a lot of empirical evidence
so for both those reasons we trust the
central limit theorem and for both those
reasons we trust the
bootstrap and we should let me see if I
can pull up some experiments showing you
how quickly it
converges
okay if you want to figure out standard
bar error bars for estimate variance
we're going to use the exact same
algorithm it's just we're going to place
these two things with variance in the
loop instead of means we're going to
calculate variances so we're going to
repeat 10,000 times first well first
before we repeat 10,000 times we're
going to estimate the probity Mass
function from our sample so we took our
200 people said that's the distribution
of happiness in Bhutan then 10,000 time
we pulled 200 new people from that proba
mass
function and then this is where it
deviates from these 200 people that we
just pulled don't calculate the mean
we're talking about the distribution of
sample variance so so let's calculate
the sample variance if you calculate the
sample variance you know we've got an
equation for that maybe this time you
get
4727 we're going to repeat this 10,000
times so the next
time we might get we will get 200
different people and this time when we
calculate the sample variance from those
200 people you'll get a different number
and if you repeat this 10,000 times
you'll have 10,000 different estimates
of the sample variance and when you see
a list what should you
think
prob okay let's try that again when you
see a list what should you
think yeah if that is a list of samples
that it should be a probability
distribution in your mind and the way
you could get there is you could think
list then go histogram the normalize
histogram because of this you know first
definition of
probability that histogram is going to
be a probability Mass function so if you
want to see it as a graph that's how you
do your translation but a list is a
distribution so so now we have a
distribution it's not talking about
particularly the variance of Happiness
it's a distribution of or sorry this is
the full distribution of things we could
have gotten from our sample variance
like in one experiment we could have
gotten this number in a different
experiment we could have gotten this
number in different experim we could
have gotten this number after 20,000
times this is all the different numbers
we think we could have gotten from
asking 200 people their happiness and
then calculating stample
variance and then if we were to plot
it you would get those that whole list
would give us a
distribution and you can calculate the
standard deviation from this
distribution Insanity yes question how
in the beginning we talked about the
spread around the number that we had
originally calculated yes so I just
wanted to relate relate that to this
sort of you know whatever number we're
coming out of from this distribution
so before we did all of this you could
have just taken your sample and
calculated the sample variance and you
have one number so you have the one
number which is the bar that we were
putting in our
report and now we have these 10,000
numbers and that will give us the in
this case they'll just give us the error
bars for that
bar I don't one thing I would mention if
you took all of these 10,000 samples and
you calculate the mean of them you would
get something exceptionally close to
that original number you
calculated so when you just took your
200 people and just calculated sample
variance if you took the mean of this
distribution it'd be basically the same
because it was an unbiased
estimate unbiased estimate by doing the
division by n minus one I don't
understand how do we like why does the
minus one make a difference oh there's a
deep deep answer to that let's talk
offline because it'll it'll go
long
okay craziness
the beautiful part of this is we can now
put error bars on our report to the king
of Bhutan I'm going to give us a
pedagogical pause I want people to come
ask me questions there in two minutes
try and crystallize what we've learned
so far uh and I'm going to leave the
bootstrapping algorithm up here it's a
beautiful powerful thing it's not that
many lines of code and it's going to let
you do some real magic with probability
so take two minutes think about life ask
some questions come find me uh and then
we will continue this wonderful
conversation
yeah yeah because it's like we're trying
to talk about how bad are estimate when
we when we talk to 200 with these people
so that's why it should always be 200 if
we you know if you had 10,000 if we had
sample 10,000 people you'd expect our
sample variance the variance of our
estimate would be very small talk to so
many people that like if you talk to
10,000 different people you probably get
a pretty similar number um so it does
matter how many people you talk to that
will change how you'll change your error
bars
yes no you always the exact same number
always exact same number good
question
e
spr
EX
such question such
conversation I'd like to repeat two
things that came up in conversation
first of all I appreciate that I first
made you think about sample variance and
then we're measuring the spread of
sample variance itself it's like you're
talking about the variance of variance
and then I promised somebody in
questions I'll never make you go one
level deeper it'll never be the variance
of variance of variance the other thing
is you know people some a really good
question is what are we doing here can
you just restate what we're doing here I
feel like that's a nice way to come back
from the pedagogical
pause people everywhere in life are are
giving you statistics and anytime
somebody gives you a statistic they
should tell you how wrong they think
they are and in science this is a
must in in news it's not always a must
but it really should be some statistics
is easy to know how wrong you are a
sample mean it's easy to know because of
central limit theorem but that's very
much a special case most statistics that
get reported to you that are not sample
means there's no good language for
talking about how wrong you
were sample variance is not sample mean
it's just my first example of some
statistic that we could be reporting for
which there's no good language for
talking about how bad your estimate was
and we really want to talk about how bad
our estimates were because as we know
from CS 109 those who can express how
wrong they are make better decisions and
so anytime you see a claim in a
newspaper about a statistic anytime you
see a claim in science about statistics
you should always ask yourself how wrong
could they be and there's lots of things
that could lead to this source of error
like if you only talk to 200 people you
might be pretty wrong if you talk to
10,000 people maybe you're less wrong
maybe I have more confidence in your
claim but you should be able to give me
in the language of probability how
confident you are in your claim enter
the bootstrap the bootstrap will allow
us to talk about how confident we are in
any
statistic even if it doesn't follow the
central limit theorem it's going to blow
past just being able to talk about how
wrong we are for sample
means okay
so this wasn't too many lines of code
but I've got good news for you guys we
can make it less you don't have to like
if you write five lines of code nobody
be like that was way excessive um but
there is a way to do this a little bit
more efficiently if you don't follow the
more efficient one that's not a problem
but maybe by showing you the more
efficient one it might give you some
cool inspiration or some cool
insights the idea is if you are told
I've got some samples from those samples
build a PM and then pull K new samples
from that we've already seen how you
could do that you could build your
histogram you could normalize it and
then you could Loop K times and pull
from that probability Mass function or
you could do
this you could say choose K things from
these samples with replacement it turns
out if you don't put this with
replacement you get completely the wrong
thing actually going back to this
example if I say I have these five
things
choose five things without replacement
you'll get exactly two zeros and three
ones every time that's not what we want
sometimes we want to get five zeros but
we want to be driven by this probability
Mass function but if you put replace
equals true and I say pull five things
from these five objects two zeros and
three ones with replacement the first
time it'll choose one object from your
five and the next time it'll choose one
object from the five but it could still
be a zero you could still draw five
zeros if you pull with replacement with
replacement means every time you take a
sample you leave it in there so that the
next one could be that exact same
sample and for those of you who are
curious you could prove to yourselves
that this is equivalent to build the
pmf then draw samples from that
probability Mass function draw case
samples so there you have it a very very
very fast way of doing the sample and
replacing let's talk about how this up
dates our OG bootstrapping so this is a
bootstrapping we had before first you
estimate the probabbly mass function
then 10,000 times you repeat your
experiment in the experiment you draw
200 people from Bhutan you calculate the
statistic you cared about and then you
have a distribution of your
statistic so now I don't know why I have
that photo there forgive me uh but it's
very inspiring maybe because we're
feeling inspired now we don't actually
have to explicitly make the prob Mass
function the sample as a list list is in
fact the probably Mass function and if
we choose 200 items from this list with
replacement that's the same as first
construct the probably Mass function and
then draw 200 samples from that
constructed pmf it is equivalent to just
pulling 200 things from your original
sample with replacement now to be clear
if there's only one of these that you
understand I want it to be this one
because that's where the theory deres
from and this is just the programming
shortcut but if you're really excited to
think about why programming shortcut is
correct I would encourage you to do so
because I do think it will just
reinforce some fundamentals if you're
curious the rest of the algorithms
exactly the same yeah what are we
cutting out like what's the shortcut so
in the first one before we do 10,000
steps we actually construct a physical
probably Mass
function yeah and now we don't have to
construct the actual probably Mass
function we just keep have a list of
original samples around and then we
sample from that with
replacement
crazy okay we have to code this we can't
talk about this in theory anymore we've
got to see some code are you guys
ready
okay I have a world for you that's going
to put this to the
test I'm going to make a random country
and that random country is going to have
a thousand people in
it
uh and sorry and it's going to when you
call when I make this random
country I'm going to know the true
variance of the people in the country
because I made the country and then I'm
going to give you a sample of Happiness
from it so I know the right answer
because I made the country don't use
this okay just use your sample and your
question is from the sample can you
guess the right answer but can you also
Express how wrong you might be in your
guess and so we're going to
bootstrap we're going to repeat 10,000
times and what are we going to repeat
bootstrap that VAR yeah
one
resample a
new
group
recalculate the stat we care
about now in this case we're talking
about um
the the variance so what we should the
cat the stat we care about is going to
be the sample variance in this
case okay how do we resample a new group
one option would be to say like probably
Mass function equals create pmf from
this list of 30 people and then we could
try and pull 30
people from pmma we could say take that
pmf and give me 30 people from it that's
what we could have done but I am going
to try and use the programming shortcut
in the programming shortcut instead of
doing this I'm just going to do
np.
random.
Choice and then I'm going to say take my
original
sample from them we're going to choose
people and replace is going to be equal
to true
let me just print this
out and let's just look at it for one
time through the
loop and then we can think about our
lives you guys ready for
it okay one time through the loop I got
30 people and that's their number that's
great that's not the end of it I'm
supposed to recal calate the statistics
so in this case calculate sample
variance with the new sample so I have a
function which does what we did on
Monday's class and I'll call that s squ
or something uh and then I'm going to
put that into my
list and now when I run this 10,000
times I'll end up with a list of 10,000
numbers for my variances uh and if and
then I'm going to I have a little
histogram plot of it oh and look at my
variances
isn't that kind of interesting and once
you have this you can talk about lots of
things I have my whole distribution
variances I can be um so the true
variance was
24.7 my estimated variance using sample
24.6 so I was a little bit off
uh and well actually I was lucky to be
that close because in fact the standard
deviation of the statistic is six so you
could be really far off so if somebody
reports to a 24.6 they got a little bit
lucky they could have reported anything
from like a 20 to a 30 um for this
particular
number okay so at this
point bootstrapping allows us to get
something like this which says we can
talk about how wrong we were in any
statistic we care about could be sample
variance could be something more
interesting uh and really it's allows
you to talk about probabilities of
Statistics using code it's a beautiful
thing quick history why is it called the
bootstrap because it's like the idea of
bootstrapping comes from this metaphor
of picking one up from your own
bootstrap so imagine you're lying down
and you have to grab your boots to get
yourself up sounds hard right and that's
why they call the bootstrap is because
this assumption that the true underlying
distribution is simple or equal to your
sample seems as hard as pulling yourself
up from your bootstrap and it's crazy
that it works out um and so that's why
it gets this name bootstrapping and it
was invented here at Stanford in 1979 by
this guy who's still a professor at
Stanford and he won a national science
medal for inventing the bootstrap I
don't do celebrity look lights uh for
for
colleagues so what I did do is I let the
internet do it so starbyface.com gave me
somebody I don't know but anyways
Bradley Efron invented the bootstrap
here at Stanford what a beautiful thing
and it works for any statistic but there
is a big as tricks your sample have to
be IID and the underlying distribution
has to be one that doesn't have a long
tail so if you guys remember the climate
change problem you explored longtail
distributions for things that are
longtail it turns out that this can
break
down which leaves us with the most
important question I claim that this can
answer a crazy important idea in science
which is you made a claim you had group
a it had its mean you had Group B and
you had its mean and from those two
things you calculate a statistic and
that statistic was the difference
between those two groups can you talk
about how wrong that statistic could
have
been there's two different ways of
talking about you can calculate the
variance of that statistic and we can do
that in exactly the same way we did
before but I do want to introduce you to
this idea of a null hypothesis that's
been in the history of science for a
very long time when comparing two groups
people often think about what's the
chance of seeing a difference this big
if my two groups were the same the null
hypothesis says you had two different
groups but they're not actually
different and any statistical difference
you saw is because you didn't do your
stats right no I'm just joking it's
because you didn't have a big enough
sample and everyone has been calculating
the probability of this null hypothesis
has a particular name it is called the P
value and bootstrapping gives us a very
nice and simple simple way to think
about the probability of the null
hypothesis it starts out with this crazy
idea so you have two lists right and you
want to know how likely it is that this
calculated difference in means is
Meaningful and the way we're going to do
that is we're going to imagine it's not
meaningful we're going to imagine the
null hypothesis in the null hypothesis
you had 20 people in group a and 20
people in group b and they're all pulls
from the same group
there's no difference between group a
and Group B you just got 20 samples from
student population and 20 other samples
in student population you called one
group a and Group B and that was totally
meaningless that's the null hypothesis
world in the null hypothesis
world the true probability Mass
function is the
concatenation of the people in
population one and population two so if
you looked at the null hypothesis world
if you had these numbers for group one
and these numbers for group two the null
hypothesis world is put all those
numbers in one big
bag and that's the distribution of
students and you just happen to pull 20
and call it group one and you just
happen to pull 20 and call it group b or
two questions about the null hypothesis
it's a weird concept once you know the
null hypothesis the bootstrapping will
come
nicely have you guys seen this before
can you nod your heads you seen null
hypothesis in other classes some folks
but it's new for other people
okay so the idea is in the null
hypothesis everything comes from one
distribution you just call this group a
and you just called this group b there's
no statistical differences between these
IID samples it's just you pulled too
little and you saw a difference in means
so in bootstrapping here's what we do we
make the universal distribution by
taking population one and extending it
with population two I make a list which
has all the people from population one
population 2 and that is the probability
Mass function of the universal
distribution 10,000 times we bootstrap
and when we bootstrap we calculate the
exact same statistic that we calculated
in our science
claim we get a group of people and call
them group a or in this case group
one we get a group of new people and
call them group two and they're all
being pulled from the Universal
population so 10,000 times we take
random people call them group one random
people call them group two and then we
calculate the mean of each of those
groups and we look at the difference in
means and then we just add it to our
list so we'll add up 10,000 differences
in
means you could count how many of them
are bigger than your observe difference
in means some people do that but I
actually want to look the full
distribution of differences and means in
this null hypothesis world so you guys
ready for
this Ready or Not Here
Comes so 10,000 times we make scientific
experiments with group a and Group B
10,000 times we calculate the statistics
this time it's not sample variance that
we're calculating the statistic we're
calculating is the difference in Sample
means that's sta statistic as
well and that statistic if you look at
it you know in the null hypothesis it's
very likely that the absolute value of
the difference in Sample means is close
to a
zero because they came from the same
distribution those two sample means are
very likely to be similar to each other
but even if you pulled 20 samples from
one group and 20 samples from another
it's still possible that or sorry if you
pull 20 from the same group and another
20 from the same group it's still
possible that they have different means
and we can calculate exactly what's the
probability
we can say using bootstrapping we know
the full distribution and the absolute
value of the difference in Sample means
and the probability that under the null
hypothesis you would have seen a
difference in means this big is what is
the probability of seeing a number in my
distribution greater than the difference
you observed and this probability you
can calculate you have the full
distribution you could just sum up all
these probabilities from your
probability Mass function of your
statistic and you say the P value the
chance of seeing a difference this big
or bigger based on the null hypothesis
is 0.008 and if you know the famous
science claim if you have P value less
than 0.05 it gets accepted into science
which is its own
problem so the idea
here every science result needs a P
value so a lot of science results are
statistics I had two groups I calculated
their means and the difference in means
means the effect size is 7 that
statistic we need to know how bad it is
we could just look at the variance of
that statistic but in science we often
look like what's the probability that
you could have seen the statistic
assuming your groups were exactly the
same bootstrapping what an incredibly
powerful tool it works for so many
different questions you could ask it
allows you to use your computer to run
10,000 simulations incredibly quickly to
understand distributions of any claim
you're making if you can understand the
distributions of any claim you're making
you can talk about it more
probabilistically it makes this insane
assumption which we're still going to
dig a little bit deeper into which is
that a great assumption for your
underlying distribution is just the
histogram of your
samples questions before we jump into I
do have one food for thought to leave
you with though this is the most
important takeaway is what I've got up
right now yes say
the P
value is the probability that under the
null
hypothesis therefore everybody is coming
from the same distribution that you
would have seen a difference in means
this big or bigger or a different or
whatever statistic you claimed so I
claimed that my difference in means was
greater than 7 that was my claim so you
would have seen a claim that strong or
stronger under the N null hypothesis
what's the probability of seeing a claim
that strong or stronger in this case my
claim is the absolute value and the
difference and means is
7 and you guys will practice this in
section yes how did you make the
universal good
question this beautiful line of
code I could have even done it without
the Deep copy U but I just wanted to
keep my population
around
these two lines of code I created a list
I put everybody in population one in it
and then I added everybody in population
two in it that is the universal
distribution good
question okay you guys are wonderful
this is one of the harder classes to
follow on thank you guys so much for
working so hard I tried my best to make
it as clear as possible you will get to
practice this in section you'll look
about corgis on Islands it's a good time
have a fantastic time in section so
wonderful to see you see you guys back
in class on
Friday